You can do anything because you have Lambda. And this year is a special edition because it's the 10th anniversary. For 10 years we've been organizing Lambda Days in Krakow in Poland to spread the word about functional languages. We wanted to create a space where we can bring some of these females together, create a platform where they feel like they can be really open and outspoken, without judgment and so they share tools and ideas well if you have any dysfunctional programming it's a lisp
你可以做任何事，因为你有 Lambda。今年是一个特别的版本，因为这是十周年纪念。10 年来，我们一直在波兰克拉科夫组织 Lambda Days，以传播函数式语言。我们希望创造一个空间，把这些女性聚集在一起，建立一个平台，让她们觉得可以真正开放、直言不讳，而不受评判，这样她们就可以很好地分享工具和想法。如果你做任何非函数式编程，那它就是 Lisp。
so it's a list processing language that is used in production systems so it's the roots are like scheme or racket if you've done that and then i went back and do you know what has happened some of the people that i was talking to, the junior people that I was talking to, had become the bosses. So it was a very unusual tech transfer strategy. Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, episode 134, recorded on June 6, 2023. My name is Connor, and on today's episode, we interview speakers and organizers live from Lambda Days 2023 that took place in Krakow, Poland. On today's episode, we interview Barbara Trojeka, Becca Williams, Jordan Miller, and Simon Payton-Jones. This is part two of our two-part Live from Lambda Days series.
所以它是一种用于生产系统的列表处理语言，它的根源类似于 Scheme 或 Racket，如果你用过的话。然后我回过头去，你知道发生了什么吗？我聊过的一些人，我聊过的那些初级人员，已经成了老板。所以这是一个非常寻常的技术转移策略。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 134 期，录制于 2023 年 6 月 13 日。我是康纳（Connor），在今天的节目中，我们现场采访了在波兰克拉科夫举行的 2023 年 Lambda Days 的演讲者和组织者。在今天的节目中，我们采访了芭芭拉·特罗耶卡（Barbara Trojeka）、贝卡·威廉姆斯（Becca Williams）、乔丹·米勒（Jordan Miller）和西蒙·佩顿-琼斯（Simon Payton-Jones）。这是我们“来自 Lambda Days 的现场”系列两部分的第二部分。
All right, we're here with Barbara, conference organizer of Lambda Days 2023. Tell us, how's the conference been going? Why is this year special? And why should people be interested in coming to Lambda Days in the future? Hi, the conference is going really well. It's the second day. The first one was very interesting
好的，我们现在和 2023 年 Lambda Days 的会议组织者芭芭拉在一起。请告诉我们，会议进行得怎么样？为什么今年很特别？为什么大家以后应该有兴趣来参加 Lambda Days？嗨，会议进展得很顺利。今天是第二天。第一天非常有趣，
because for the first time we have panel discussions, a little bit more open to the audience, and they went really good. Today is mainly the day of talks, and I hope this is going to go similarly well. And this year is a special edition because it's the 10th anniversary. For 10 years, we've been organizing Lambda Days in Krakow in Poland to spread the word about functional languages to the European community mainly,
因为我们第一次举办了小组讨论，对观众更加开放一点，效果非常好。今天主要是演讲日，我希望今天也能同样顺利。今年是一个特别的版本，因为这是十周年纪念。10 年来，我们一直在波兰克拉科夫组织 Lambda Days，主要是向欧洲社区传播函数式语言，
but of course we have guests from all around the world. Yeah. And why should folks, you know, if the people listening to this podcast, you know, haven't been to any conferences, or maybe they've been to some, but they haven't been to Lambda Days, why should they come and check out Lambda Days in Krakow, Poland? I think Lambda Days is a little bit different than if you, for example, if you code in Erlang, Elixir, Scala,
当然，我们也有来自世界各地的嘉宾。是的。那么为什么大家——你知道，如果听这个播客的人没有参加过任何会议，或者可能参加过一些但没参加过 Lambda Days——为什么他们应该来波兰克拉科夫看一看 Lambda Days？我认为 Lambda Days 有点不同，例如如果你用 Erlang、Elixir、Scala 编程，
you probably will go to CodeBeam Conference, ElixirConf, or Scalac, or something like that to learn about your own language. But Lambda is a little bit different because you learn about other languages, but also functional languages, so you can take that knowledge and see if you can implement that into your language or your work or whatever project you're working on.
你可能会去 CodeBeam 会议、ElixirConf、Scalac 或类似的东西来了解你自己的语言。但 Lambda 有点不同，因为你可以了解其他语言，还有函数式语言，这样你就可以吸取这些知识，看看能否将其应用到你的语言、你的工作或你正在进行的任何项目中。
And also, on top of that, Lambda Days works really closely with researchers, so we have research talks from all different universities. So the ideas clash because researchers have their own crazy ideas and then people who actually work on those things come to them and say, well, how would this work and how would that work? So yeah, it's like a clash of ideas. So it's very interesting, awesome talks.
不仅如此，Lambda Days 还与研究人员紧密合作，因此我们有来自各大高校的研究演讲。这些想法会发生碰撞，因为研究人员有他们自己疯狂的想法，然后真正从事这些工作的人会走到他们面前说，这怎么行得通，那又怎么行得通？所以，是的，这就像是思想的碰撞。因此，这里有非常有趣、精彩的演讲。
Yeah, that's why you should come to Lambda Days. It is pretty awesome that we had the CEO of Epic Games, Tim Sweeney, giving a keynote alongside Simon Peyton-Jones, who hopefully we'll be able to interview later. We haven't found him yet, but super awesome that someone clearly from industry, you know, Epic Games, massive, multi-billion dollar company, giving a keynote alongside Simon Payton Jones, who, if you don't know, is one of the main fathers of Haskell.
是的，这就是你应该来 Lambda Days 的原因。Epic Games 的首席执行官蒂姆·斯威尼（Tim Sweeney）与西蒙·佩顿-琼斯（Simon Payton-Jones）一起发表主题演讲，这真是太棒了，我们希望稍后能采访到西蒙。我们还没找到他，但是，一个来自工业界的人——你知道，Epic Games，一家规模庞大、市值数十亿美元的公司——能与西蒙·佩顿-琼斯（如果你不知道的话，他可以说是 Haskell 的主要之父之一）一起发表主题演讲，真的非常棒。
Pretty awesome to see that. I've got two questions from previous people that we've interviewed earlier today. The first one's from Toby. We had one after party this year at Lambda Days 2023. Toby said that there's going to be two next year. Can you confirm or deny whether that is the case? I cannot confirm nor deny, because we'll see. We'll see. We can't deny. So Toby might be telling the truth. The second question is when we talked to Jose Valim, creator of the Elixir language, we were asked to ask you, maybe it was, you know, I might have, I might've been the person.
看到这一点真是太棒了。我有来自今天早些时候我们采访过的前几位嘉宾的两个问题。第一个来自托比。今年在 2023 年 Lambda Days 上我们有一个会后派对。托比说明年会有两个。你能证实或否认事实是否如此吗？我既不能证实也不能否认，因为我们会拭目以待。我们会拭目以待。我们不能否认。所以托比可能说的是真的。第二个问题是，当我们与 Elixir 语言的创造者何塞·瓦利姆（Jose Valim）交谈时，我们被要求问你，也许是，你知道的，可能是我，可能我就是那个人。
What's, what's Lambda Day's favorite language? You know, do you have a, do you have a favorite language, you know, of, of the languages that are talked about at this conference? Can you choose one live on the pod? And Jose Valim asked that question. I mean, was it Jose? Was it me? Nobody knows. Nobody knows. I don't think I can answer that question live, no. But you do have a favorite, or can you confirm and deny that much at least?
Lambda Days 最喜欢的语言是什么？你知道的，在本次会议讨论的语言中，你有没有最喜欢的语言？你能在播客现场选一个吗？何塞·瓦利姆提出了这个问题。我是说，是何塞吗？是我吗？没人知道。没人知道。我觉得我不能现场回答这个问题，不。但你确实有一个最喜欢的，或者你至少可以证实或否认到这个程度？
No, I don't, because I'm not a programmer, so I don't have a favorite language. And I think every community that's a functional programming community is very inclusive. People are very open, very casual. That's why I love to work here, because, yeah, they're great. They're great. They love the food, and they love the parties. So what else can I expect? I should say, we were talking to Kim earlier who was eating the panna cotta.
不，我没有，因为我不是程序员，所以我没有最喜欢的语言。而且我认为每一个函数式编程社区都非常具有包容性。大家都很开放，很随意。这就是为什么我喜欢在这里工作，因为，是的，他们太棒了。他们太棒了。他们喜欢这里的食物，喜欢这里的派对。那我还能期待什么呢？我得说，我们之前和正在吃意式奶冻的金（Kim）聊过。
She gave it a four to five stars. She loved it. And we said that the vegan cake probably sounded vegan, but I had it. And let me tell you, it was actually quite delicious. I might have had two slices. That's good. That's great. Yeah.
她给它打了四到五星。她很喜欢。我们说纯素蛋糕听起来可能是纯素的，但我尝过了。实话告诉你，其实相当美味。我可能吃了两块。那很好。太棒了。是的。
Yeah. So you can find vegan, vegetarian food here. Or, yeah, we can accommodate vegan, vegetarian food here, or we can accommodate you, whatever dietary requirements you have. And if people want to follow Lambda Days or yourself on socials, what's the best place to do that? We have Twitter, Instagram. On Twitter, we are at Lambda Days.
所以你可以在这里找到纯素、素食。或者，是的，我们可以在这里提供纯素、素食，或者我们可以满足你的任何饮食要求。如果人们想在社交媒体上关注 Lambda Days 或你自己，最好的地方在哪里？我们有 Twitter、Instagram。在 Twitter 上，我们是 @Lambda Days。
Yes, just at Lambda Days. That's our handle. LinkedIn as well. Yeah, for now, those three channels I think will be best. Awesome. We will link all that stuff in the show notes if folks are interested. Thank you so much for being interviewed and also for all the work and the team of people around you.
是的，就是 @Lambda Days。这就是我们的用户名。还有 LinkedIn。是的，目前，这三个渠道我觉得是最好的。太棒了。如果大家感兴趣，我们会在节目简介中链接所有这些内容。非常感谢你接受采访，也感谢你以及你周围的团队所做的一切工作。
I know it's not just a one-person show. All the work you put into organizing this conference has been awesome so far. Yeah, thank you for coming and speaking and doing the lightning talks. Thanks so much. Awesome, thank you. All right, we're almost at the end of Lambda Days 2023, day two. We're here with Becca Williams, who gave the last lightning talk of six lightning talks this morning.
我知道这不仅仅是一个人的独角戏。到目前为止，你为组织这次会议所付出的所有工作都非常棒。是的，谢谢你们来演讲并做闪电演讲。非常感谢。太棒了，谢谢。好的，我们即将迎来 2023 年 Lambda Days 第二天的尾声。我们现在和贝卡·威廉姆斯（Becca Williams）在一起，她发表了今天上午六个闪电演讲中的最后一个。
And she was talking about an organization that I had never heard of before attending this conference, Functional Females. So first I'll let you give a brief introduction of yourself and then maybe tell us about the organization and what people should know about it. So I've been in recruitment for a couple of years now and it's always been within functional programming. The last two months or so, myself and my colleague Olivia have set up a community called Functional Females.
她谈到了一个我在参加这次会议之前从未听说过的组织：Functional Females（函数式女性）。因此，首先我请你对你自己做一个简单的介绍，然后给我们讲讲这个组织以及人们应该了解它的什么。我在招聘行业已经干几年了，而且一直专注于函数式编程领域。在过去两个月左右的时间里，我和我的同事奥利维亚（Olivia）建立了一个名为 Functional Females 的社区。
I think with us being within recruitment we know the talent pool, we've seen the talent pool, we look at it every single day within our jobs when we're hiring whether it's in Elixir or Scala or Rust we see the talent pool and for us we go through 40-50 male developers and then we come across one female developer and then so on so on so we wanted to create a space where we can bring some of these females together um create like a platform where they feel like they can be really open and outspoken like without judgment and so they share tools and ideas it is predominantly a slack community but we've also held like um virtual meetups and we plan to have uh in-person meetups later on in the year um but yeah we they share tools they share ideas like for us as recruiters we give them a lot of advice on like tackling the
我想，由于我们身处招聘领域，我们了解人才库，我们见过人才库，我们在工作中每天招聘时都会看到它，无论是在 Elixir、Scala 还是 Rust 领域，我们都看到了人才库。对我们来说，我们会浏览 40 到 50 名男性开发者，然后才会遇到一名女性开发者，以此类推。因此，我们想要创建一个空间，把其中一些女性聚集在一起，嗯，创建一个平台，让她们觉得可以真正开放、直言不讳，而不受评判，这样她们就可以分享工具和想法。它主要是一个 Slack 社区，但我们也举办过虚拟聚会，并计划在今年晚些时候举办线下聚会。但是，是的，她们分享工具，分享想法。对于我们作为招聘人员来说，我们给了她们很多关于应对
job market as well as what the job market looks like and it's also great for us because a lot of the companies that we work with they speak to us about the challenges and struggles they have when it comes to hiring a diverse team and also retaining a diverse team so we can speak to these women about these challenges within the company and it's more of a safe space for them so that we can speak to other companies and hopefully tackle the the challenges start from the inside out and when we get new roles on our desk the our first point of call now well my first point of call is always functional females like let's speak to these
就业市场以及就业市场现状的建议。这对我们来说也非常好，因为我们合作的许多公司都会向我们讲述他们在招聘多元化团队以及留住多元化团队时遇到的挑战和困难。因此，我们可以与这些女性讨论公司内部的这些挑战，这对她们来说是一个更安全的环境，这样我们就可以与其他公司对话，有望从内到外地解决这些挑战。当新的职位来到我们桌上时，我们的第一联系点——好吧，我现在的首要联系点总是 Functional Females——让我们和这些女性谈谈，
women let's see if this is the right role for them let's speak to the talent pool that i found of women in functional programming and then go to the males because everyone like you can speak to a hundred developers here like these male developers they still get reached out to to require recruiters three four times a day probably so to me it's not like it's unjust it's like just giving females a bit more of an um like a a chance than what they may have received like throughout their career really so this sounds absolutely like an awesome initiative and when talking to kim earlier she mentioned i'm not sure if it was while we were recording or while we were not recording that
看看这是否适合她们，和我在函数式编程中找到的女性人才库谈谈，然后再去找男性。因为每个人——你可以在这里和 100 个开发者交谈，这些男性开发者仍然一天可能被招聘人员联系三四次。所以对我来说，这并不觉得是不公正的，这就像是给女性比她们在整个职业生涯中可能得到的更多的机会。所以这听起来绝对是一个棒极了的倡议。之前和金交谈时，她提到——我不确定是在我们录音时还是在录音外——
this just launched two months ago and so are you mostly based in europe right now because i know kim said she's based out of the netherlands and i think she said was the Scala lead. And so is it like one lead per sort of functional language? Could you give like a little bit more details of if people are listening to this? Because I think we have listeners all over the globe, some in North America, some in Europe, like, what can people expect, like if they're looking for meetups or looking to get involved? So we want everyone to join that there's no expectation on anyone that they can use it for the little things that they need, whether they are on the job market and they're interested in the like interview tips or they want to just connect with other females within functional programming
这个项目才刚刚推出两个月，所以你们现在主要立足于欧洲吗？因为我知道金说她住在荷兰，我想她说她是 Scala 的负责人。这是否意味着每种函数式语言大约有一个负责人？如果你能提供更多详细信息，以防有人在听这个？因为我想我们的听众遍布全球，有些在北美，有些在欧洲。如果他们正在寻找聚会或想要参与其中，他们可以期待什么？所以我们希望每个人都能加入，对任何人都没有期望，他们可以根据需要的小事来使用它，无论他们是在就业市场上对面试技巧感兴趣，还是只想与函数式编程中的其他女性建立联系，
but we are at the moment just across europe although it has been two months since launching we're at around sort of 80 90 developer female developers at the moment um i think it's europe right now just because we've always like that's where we've built our network for the last couple of years um and like we know a lot of developers within this space and when it comes to later on in the year with our growth plans and doing a meetup it'll be a lot easier to have it in one sort of space but we've got i think around 24 different countries now so yeah it's definitely spread across Europe and 100% the plan will be to like open it up widen it up across like the US and stuff but it's just where our resources are at the moment we're focusing on Europe and then we're
但目前我们只在欧洲各地。虽然自推出以来已经过去两个月了，但目前我们大约有 80 到 90 名女性开发者。嗯，我认为目前在欧洲只是因为我们在过去几年里一直是在那里建立我们的网络，而且我们在这个领域认识很多开发者。当谈到今年晚些时候的增长计划和举办聚会时，把活动放在一个地方会更容易一些。但我想我们现在大约有 24 个不同的国家，所以是的，它绝对传播到了欧洲。100% 的计划是在美国等地将其开放和扩大，但这只是我们目前的资源所在，我们专注于欧洲，然后我们
working to expand from there. That sounds so awesome 24 countries in two months is that's massive growth very quickly. So the question I have to ask is, I am primarily a C++ developer. You said you have like a Rust. Is there space for the non, I mean, like C++ has some functional stuff, but it's definitely not known as a functional language. So is there languages you're focusing on, or is there like certain, I know Rust, Scala have been mentioned, like what are the main languages you're focusing on, Or is there certain... I know Rust, Scala have been mentioned.
努力从那里开始扩张。听起来太棒了，两个月内有 24 个国家，这是非常迅速的巨大增长。所以我要问的问题是，我主要是一个 C++ 开发者。你说过你们有像 Rust 这样的语言。这里有非...我的意思是，C++ 有一些函数式的东西，但它绝对不以函数式语言闻名。那么你们有专注的语言吗，或者有一些特定的...我知道 Rust 和 Scala 已经被提及了，你们主要专注的是哪些语言？或者有没有某些...我知道 Rust 和 Scala 已经被提及了。
What are the main languages you're focusing on? And is there hope for C++? So, yeah, I know I've been told so many times in my career that Rust isn't actually a functional programming language. So I think that's just where... That's an area that we've worked in as well. But at the moment, we've got channels for um scala elixir erlang rust um haskell closure but yeah there's always like room for more like we want to
你们主要关注的是哪些语言？C++ 还有希望吗？所以，是的，我知道在我的职业生涯中，有人无数次告诉我 Rust 实际上不是函数式编程语言。所以我认为这只是——这也是我们工作过的一个领域。但目前，我们有关于 Scala、Erlang、Rust、Haskell、Clojure 的频道。但，是的，总是有更多语言的空间——我们希望鼓励更多女性进入技术领域。我们希望拥有一个空间，让更多的女性想要进入技术领域，并有望进入函数式编程。
encourage women within like technology like we want to have a space where more women are wanting to head into technology and hopefully into functional programming. But yeah, there's always space for more languages. We just want people to feel open to come to us and say, yeah, I'm working in C++. I'm really interested in the functional programming paradigms. And yeah, I'd love to be able to hopefully host a space for them as well. Awesome. So if there's folks that are listening across the globe and they're thinking
但，是的，总有更多语言的空间。我们只希望人们能够毫无保留地来找我们并说，是的，我在用 C++。我对函数式编程范式非常感兴趣。是的，我很希望能为她们也主持这样一个空间。太棒了。因此，如果世界各地的听众在想，
I know Python and I love functional programming and I want to get involved some way, where's the place to go or the thing to do? The next step, if you will. So come to me, come to Becca Williams on LinkedIn. Also Olivia Smith. At the moment, we are
我懂 Python，我热爱函数式编程，我想以某种方式参与进来，该去哪里或者该做些什么？可以说是下一步。所以来找我，在 LinkedIn 上找贝卡·威廉姆斯（Becca Williams）。还有奥利维亚·史密斯（Olivia Smith）。目前，我们正
trying to get to as many conferences as much as possible just to spread awareness. But we do have a functional females LinkedIn. But, yeah, we're just taking email, like doing bog standard way, taking some emails, adding them to our Slack channel. And we're growing just by word of mouth as well, which has been fantastic. Awesome. Thank you so much. Thank you for being on the pod. And we'll make sure that we link to your Twitter, Olivia's Twitter,
尽量参加尽可能多的会议，只是为了传播意识。但我们确实有一个 Functional Females 的 LinkedIn。但是，是的，我们只是在接受电子邮件，用老掉牙的方式，收集一些电子邮件，把它们添加到我们的 Slack 频道中。而且我们也只是通过口碑在不断成长，这真是太棒了。太棒了非常感谢。谢谢你来到播客。我们将确保链接到你的 Twitter、奥利维亚的 Twitter、
Functional Females, LinkedIn, and any other links that you want me to link so if folks are interested, they can get involved. No worries. Thank you so much. I got caught making a beeline for the espresso machine. I got caught making a beeline for the espresso machine. Are you recording? Of course you are. We're recording. You need to tell people when you start. I told told everybody else but i figured it would just be perfect if i
Functional Females 的 LinkedIn，以及你希望我链接的任何其他链接，以便感兴趣的人可以参与进来。别客气。非常感谢。我被抓到直奔浓缩咖啡机去了。我被抓到直奔浓缩咖啡机去了。你在录音吗？你当然在录音。我们在录音。你得在开始时告诉大家。我告诉了其他人，但我想如果我
just turned you you were mid-story you were mid-story i walk in i'm making a v-line for the espresso machine because of course it's the morning right it's morning right now and on my way over said hey do you have five minutes to one one video? And I'm like, can I have a coffee first? But then I was trying to hold my coffee to get that out of the shot. So I had to gulp, and then I had to look directly in the eye. I was like, no, the videographer had the shot set up. And I'm like, I cannot just stare. I cannot think and stare
直接把你...你当时正在讲故事。我走进来，直奔浓缩咖啡机，因为当然是早上，对吧？现在是早上。在走过去的路上，有人说，嘿，你有五分钟拍个视频吗？我说，我能先喝杯咖啡吗？但随后我试图拿着咖啡把它挡在镜头外面。所以我不得不猛吞一口，然后我必须直视对方的眼睛。我当时想，不，摄像师已经设置好了镜头。我心想，我不能只是盯着。我不能一边思考一边盯着
somebody in the eye at the same time who does that this is very inconsiderate not letting you hold your coffee declaring that you make eye contact directly with the camera i can't make no not with the camera i would be able to look at the camera you had to make contact with the videographer yes yes yes with the videographer much like i'm making eye contact with you. Nobody can see right now, but we're locked, locked in deep eye contact right now. Folks, we are talking to the, I was about to say the man, the myth, the legend. What's the female equivalent to the... The man, the myth, the legend. I think that crosses the that crosses the the the gender threshold i guess um
某人的眼睛，谁会这样做？这太不体贴了，不让你拿着咖啡，还宣布你要直接与镜头对视。我不能做，不，不是与镜头，我能看着镜头。你必须与摄像师接触。是的，是的，与摄像师接触，就像我现在正在与你对视一样。现在没人能看到，但我们此刻紧锁着目光，深情对视。各位，我们正在和——我刚想说那个男人、那个神话、那个传奇。女性版本的……那个男人、那个神话、那个传奇。我认为这打破了……这打破了性别界限，我想，
but we're here with jordan miller host of everybody's favorite slightly out of commission podcast lost in lambdas coming back i'm coming back i'm coming back you inspired me last night i mean we because it's it's such it's such you think it's's not like there is a big ability for feedback mechanism, especially since Twitter imploded. I don't even know where, how to publicize that I do new releases anymore. I mean, Twitter still is there. It's still a thing. Is it, though? I mean, I haven't switched to Mastodon, but that's just because I have too many Twitter accounts
但我们在这里和乔丹·米勒（Jordan Miller）在一起，她是大家最喜欢的略微暂停运营的播客《迷失在 Lambda 中》（Lost in Lambdas）的主持人。我要回来了。我要回来了。我要回来了。你昨天激励了我。我是说，我们因为——因为它是——它是——你认为它不是——没有很大的反馈机制能力，特别是自从 Twitter 崩溃之后。我甚至不知道，不知道该怎么宣传我做新发布了。我是说，Twitter 依然还在。它还是个东西。真的是吗？我是说，我没有转到 Mastodon，那只是因为我有太多的 Twitter 账号，
and the overhead of having to switch each of them, like my personal one, my podcast one. I have one Twitter. I'm just waiting to see for the dust to settle because if maybe Twitter will come back. Come back. It's still, it's still. Are you on Macedon? Are you just, you? No, no, I'm waiting.
而且必须切换每一个账号的管理开销很大，比如我的个人账号，我的播客账号。我有一个 Twitter。我只是在等着看尘埃落定，因为也许 Twitter 会卷土重来。卷土重来。它还在，它还在。你在 Mastodon 上吗？还是只有你？不，不，我在等。
I'm waiting to see what everybody chooses because I'm out of social media. You know, I recently denied Snapchat forever too, but my family recently got me on Snapchat. And actually, even making my first Twitter was like, I'm done. I wanted to stop at Instagram, but here we here we are 2023 with 2023 accounts to manage. If you, if you start making podcast episodes again, I will, I will plug the releases on, on both of my personal and my, this podcast. You've been busy though. So first of all, for folks, for folks that don't know Jordan, she's got a, she's got a pod part of the closure community. Actually, I'll let you introduce yourself first.
我在等着看大家选择什么，因为我已经退出了社交媒体。你知道，我最近也永远拒绝了 Snapchat，但我的家人最近把我拉上了 Snapchat。实际上，甚至创建我的第一个 Twitter 时，我就想，我受够了。我想在 Instagram 停下来，但这里我们来到了 2023 年，有 2023 个账号要管理。如果你——如果你重新开始制作播客节目，我会在我个人的和这个播客上都推广新发布。不过你一直很忙。所以首先，对于那些不了解乔丹的人来说，她有一个播客，是 Clojure 社区的一部分。实际上，我先让你自我介绍一下。
But I first stumbled across Jordan Miller when she was a guest, I don't know which episode. It was probably episode 147, plus or minus a few, in January of 2022. Why do I know the exact date? It's because on that, this is Cognacast, and we first heard her name then, and then we went and listened to all 17 episodes of Lost in Lambdas,
但我第一次偶然发现乔丹·米勒是在她作为嘉宾的时候，我不知道是哪一集。大概是第 147 集，上下浮动几集，在 2022 年 1 月。为什么我知道确切的日期？因为在那期节目里，这是 Cognacast，我们第一次听到她的名字，然后我们就去听了《迷失在 Lambda 中》的所有 17 集，
one of the most refreshing podcasts on the market. It's focused on sort of functional programming and stuff. Anyways, fantastic podcast. If you like programming podcasts, you like functional programming, this one is completely different. She interviews the people behind the GitHub names and the Twitter names. Anyways, that's my, that's how I came across. Love the podcast. Great to meet you in person. Introduce yourself though. Everything that I missed in sort of tell us about why people should listen to the pod. And also you're working on some exciting projects. Tell us about those as well.
这是市场上最令人耳目一新的播客之一。它专注于某种函数式编程之类的内容。总之，非常棒的播客。如果你喜欢编程播客，喜欢函数式编程，这完全是另一回事。她采访了 GitHub 名字和 Twitter 名字背后的那些人。总之，那是我的——我是如何发现这个播客的。非常喜欢这个播客。很高兴见到你真人。不过，请自我介绍一下。所有我错过的关于——告诉大家为什么人们应该听这个播客。而且你也在进行一些激动人心的项目。也跟我们讲讲那些。
Oh, okay. Time to plug myself. All right. I got this. I got this. Um, so hi, I'm Jordan. I do closure and closure script. Um um i should be more prepared with like you know entry entry things uh let's see my podcast i think you summed it up very well that i like i i really want to bring the humanity back to tech because i think all too often we have all of these uh virtual layers in between us and it's easy to forget that we're all just human and like regardless of you know there's there's even even in like sociology I guess if you look at it we have all these layers of like culture and let you know all these in real person layers but I think even then at the core, the basic human condition is the same.
哦，好吧。是时候为自己打广告了。好的。我懂了。我懂了。嗯，嗨，我是乔丹。我用 Clojure 和 ClojureScript。嗯，我应该对诸如进入之类的东西做更多准备。让我想想，我的播客，我觉得你总结得很好，我真的想把人性带回科技领域，因为我认为往往我们之间有所有这些虚拟层，很容易忘记我们都只是人，无论——你知道的——甚至在社会学中，如果你看一下，我们有所有这些文化层，你知道，所有这些真实的人际层，但我认为即便如此，核心的基本人类状况是相同的。
And if I can cut through some of the layers, then that's very motivating for me. Because then, I mean, somebody makes an amazing library, and they don't merge your pr because it's open source it's it can be very easy to get like upset because you know yeah we knew we know this like keyboard um behind a keyboard it's easy to forget people are human but if you listen to a podcast and you know the person then it's easier to work with one another and easier to connect so i should i i all right i will get the podcast back we should do an opening a season debut episode how's that like who's we us yeah all right look at look at this podcast cross pollination we we can we can either do two separate episodes and then post them individually
如果我能穿透一些层，那对我来说就很有动力。因为那样的话，我是说，有人做了一个了不起的库，而他们没有合并你的 PR，因为它是开源的，这很容易让人感到沮丧，因为你知道，是的，我们知道这个——键盘后面的——键盘后面，很容易忘记人是有人性的。但如果你听了播客，了解了这个人，那么彼此合作就会更容易，连接也会更容易。所以我应该——好的，我得把播客弄回来。我们应该做一个开场季首播集，怎么样？像谁是我们？是的。好吧，看看这种播客交叉授粉。我们既可以做两集独立的节目，然后分别发布，
or we can just do like a single episode and post them on our respective mob I've done a couple of mobcasts I think they're the most fun
也可以只做一个单集节目，然后在各自的平台上发布。我做过几次 mobcast，我觉得它们最有趣。
mobcasts I never heard that term yeah I think when did we think of it it was with Ray and Vijay with Defen oh yeah yeah
mobcast？我从来没听过这个词。是的，我想我们是什么时候想出来的？是和雷（Ray）还有维杰（Vijay）在 Defen...哦，是的，是的。
but then they also yeah they invited their guest was michelle and then we invited our friend paula and it was just a mobcast like i don't even know what and it was on my podcast their pot it was i don't know it's it's again the connection whoo um but i guess i should say why i haven't uh released episodes because i have a couple other projects going on so um we've been i co-founded originally it was called the clown soul we have rebranded to uh it's called closure camp and uh my co-organizers with that are daniel higginbotham uh you might know him from uh the famous famous
但后来他们也——是的，他们邀请了他们的嘉宾米歇尔（Michelle），然后我们邀请了我们的朋友宝拉（Paula），它就成了一个 mobcast，我甚至不知道什么——而且是在我的播客上，他们的播客上，我不知道，这又是关于连接的。呜……不过我想我应该说说为什么我没有发布新节目，因为我还有其他几个项目正在进行。所以，我们一直在——我最初共同创立了它，当时叫 The Clown Soul，我们已经重新品牌化为——它叫 Closure Camp，我的联合组织者是丹尼尔·希金博特姆（Daniel Higginbotham）——你可能从著名的
book closure for the brave and true and um and then our other friend uh paula guran and uh our friend ref ditwell and um and yeah we see that there is a problem that um the closure community has a lot of really great senior engineers and so it can be challenging for a company to justify hiring more junior engineer but that is a problem because we need fresh blood in in in the industry and uh when you think about if they're all senior engineers and a lot of people find closure 10 15 20 years into their career who were the programmers 15, 20 years ago? A lot of the same, a lot of people that share a lot of the same identity attributes. One might say.
书《勇敢而真实的 Clojure》（Clojure for the Brave and True）中认识他——然后是我们的另一个朋友宝拉·古兰（Paula Guran），还有我们的朋友雷夫·迪特维尔（Ref Ditwell）。并且，是的，我们看到这里存在一个问题，即 Clojure 社区有很多非常优秀的资深工程师，所以公司可能很难证明雇用更多初级工程师是合理的。但这却是个问题，因为我们需要行业有新鲜血液。当你想到如果他们都是资深工程师，而且很多在职业生涯 10、15、20 年后才发现 Clojure 的人——15、20 年前的程序员都是谁？很大程度上是同一拨人，很大程度上是拥有许多相同身份属性的人。有人可能会这么说。
One might say, yeah. And so part of our mission is also to prioritize the experience of people that are underrepresented in tech and then get their diversity of experience on our closure teams because you know we're solving really hard problems you know what makes solving hard problems better diversity in experience yeah and like not not not diversity for the sake of diversity because that is important but also even just selfish, I can recognize that to solve hard problems requires a creative and abstract thinking. And diversity and experience, like hive mind, never works.
有人可能会这么说，是的。所以我们的使命之一也是优先考虑科技领域代表性不足的人的体验，然后将他们多样化的经验带到我们的 Clojure 团队中，因为你知道，我们在解决非常难的问题。你知道是什么让解决难问题变得更好吗？经验的多样性。是的，而且——不是为了多元化而多元化，虽然那很重要，但即使出于自私的考虑，我也能认识到，要解决难题需要创造性和抽象思维。经验的多样性，比如集体思维，是永远行不通的。
I mean, inexperience is a form of diversity. Yeah. And that is something I relate to. Like, I don't have, you know, something. When I gave my talk yesterday was the first time I was ever in a lecture hall because I didn't go to university. So I had never, ever been in a lecture hall in real life. You skipped the university phase straight to giving lectures phase. Yeah, I guess so. I guess so.
我的意思是，缺乏经验也是一种多样性。是的，这也是我能感同身受的一点。比如，我没有——你知道的——有些东西。我昨天做演讲时，是我第一次走进阶梯教室，因为我没有上过大学。所以我以前在现实生活中从来没有进过阶梯教室。你跳过了大学阶段，直接进入了演讲阶段。是的，我想是的。我想是的。
I was doing important other things. I was effing around and I was finding out. And boy, did I find out. Found out so much. The hard school, the school of hard life. I don't know. There's an expression in there I'm forgetting. I'd help you out, but I don't know. There's an expression in there I'm forgetting. I'd help you out, but I don't know the expression. And yeah, I've been doing lots of conferences. That's been very fun. So yeah, Closure Camp is one of the projects we're getting off the ground. And our hypothesis is that if we foster facilitation in the community, that we can help solve this problem of hiring
我在忙着做其他重要的事情。我当时在瞎混，然后我找到了答案。天哪，我还真找到了。找到了那么多。艰苦的学校，生活的硬核学校。我不知道。那里有个我忘了的表达方式。我会帮你，但我不知道。那里有个我忘了的表达方式。我会帮你，但我不知道那个表达方式。而且，是的，我一直在做很多会议。那非常有趣。所以，是的，Clojure Camp 是我们正在推进的项目之一。我们的假设是，如果我们促进社区中的引导，我们就能帮助解决招聘初级工程师的问题。
junior engineers. So if we make connections with business leaders and ask what skills would help you hire a junior engineer, because we understand why, because to hire a junior engineer is a risk. And if you don't know how big that risk is, how long they're going to take to onboard, how long then, you it does it doesn't make sense logically and so if we can mitigate that risk by saying what would you like them to know
因此，如果我们与商业领袖建立联系，询问什么技能可以帮助你雇佣初级工程师，因为我们理解其中的原因——雇佣初级工程师是一种风险。如果你不知道这个风险有多大，他们需要多长时间上手，需要多长时间——那么从逻辑上讲这是说不通的。所以如果我们能通过以下方式减轻这种风险：询问你想让他们了解什么，
in building a curricula and then fostering the community of attracting um like teachers or mentors and and then students and facilitating the meetups, more like a match, almost like a matchmaking service, but not in a cohort time-based way, in a self-led through the curriculum way. And it also solves another problem in that being a mentor or a teacher can be thankless work. It can be, it's like burnout city. Anyone that's ever really tried, and you try because you're passionate about sharing what you love, and then it's just so tiring.
构建课程，然后培育吸引教师或导师以及学生的社区，并促成聚会，更像是一种匹配，几乎像是一种红娘服务，但不是按同届时间基调的方式，而是通过自导自学课程的方式。它还解决了另一个问题，即作为导师或教师可能是吃力不讨好的工作。它可能是——这简直是职业倦怠之城。任何真正尝试过的人，你之所以尝试是因为你热衷于分享你所爱的东西，然后它就太累了。
Just so tiring to always be creating and giving and giving and giving, and you like to see your students succeed, but, you know, sometimes it can feel like their successes are you know their successes are rightfully their successes but their failures are your failures and uh so that's that's one of the projects that's been taking a lot of my time um And then I'm also co-authoring a book that we should really, we're about halfway through, we should do more on. I'm co-authoring it with Alex Miller.
总是去创造、去付出、去付出、去付出，真是太累了。你喜欢看到你的学生成功，但是，你知道，有时你会觉得他们的成功是——你知道，他们的成功理所当然是他们的成功，但他们的失败就是你的失败。所以，这是占用我很多时间的其中一个项目。然后我也在合著一本书，我们其实已经完成大约一半了，我们应该在这个上面多花点精力。我和亚历克斯·米勒（Alex Miller）共同合著。
He's a Closure core contributor, and I don't know, I wonder if the listeners need an Alex explanation. Some of the listeners don't, but most of the listeners do. Because, I don't know, maybe probably 20%, 50% of our listeners have heard of Clojure, but that's probably it. Oh, well, you should really try Clojure. Pitch Clojure if you want, yeah. Well, if you have any functional programming, it's a Lisp. So it's a Lisp processing language that is used in production systems. So the roots are like Scheme or Racket, if you've done that. But a lot of it's very data-oriented.
他是 Clojure 核心贡献者，我不知道，我在想听众是否需要对亚历克斯做个解释。一部分听众不需要，但大多数听众需要。因为，我不知道，也许大概 20%、50% 的听众听说过 Clojure，但可能仅此而已。哦，好吧，你真的应该试试 Clojure。如果你愿意的话，推荐一下 Clojure。好吧，如果你做任何函数式编程，它就是 Lisp。所以它是一种用于生产系统的列表处理语言。所以它的根源就像 Scheme 或 Racket，如果你用过的话。但其中很多东西都是高度面向数据的。
And get this, no breaking changes. We don't believe in breaking changes. No, that doesn't sound right. No, seriously. So sometimes you'll see our libraries, and you can tell when someone comes from another language because they'll check out for a dependency, like, oh, what's this? Oh, no commit in a year.
而且你听着，没有破坏性变更。我们不相信破坏性变更。不，听起来不对。不，说真的。所以有时你会看到我们的库，当有人来自其他语言时，你能看出来，因为他们会查看一个依赖项，比如，哦，这是什么？哦，一年没有提交了。
And I'm like, oh, no, no, no. It's just complete. It's just done. It still works. Works as intended. Done meaning not abandoned, but just done. Yeah, yeah. It is complete.
我就想，哦，不，不，不。它只是完成了。它只是做完了。它依然能用。按预期工作。做完了的意思不是被抛弃了，而是刚刚完成。对，对。它是完整的。
There's nothing else that achieves the objective it set out to do. And that's it. But things don't go stale because there's no breaking changes. So that's the Clojure pitch. You're working on a book, too? Working on a book? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. The book.
没有什么其他东西能实现它设定的目标。就是这样。但事情不会变陈旧，因为没有破坏性变更。这就是 Clojure 的宣传。你也在写一本书？在写一本书？哦，对，对，对，对。那本书。
So it's called Clojure Brain Teasers. And it's similar. It's with Pragmatic Program prag prog and uh it is 30 different uh teasers that are the intention isn't to be like oh gotcha it's i mean maybe with the other books because there's there's there was python brain teasers and rust brain teasers but with um closure brain teasers alex has been part of the closure in slack just answering questions for like a decade now so the same questions get and like because it's a very intentionally designed language again with no breaking changes everything kind of works for like a reason like even though it may
所以它叫《Clojure 脑筋急转弯》（Clojure Brain Teasers）。它很相似。是与 Pragmatic Program（Prag Prog）合作的，它有 30 个不同的——这些谜题的意图不是那种“哦，抓到你了吧”的感觉，我的意思是，也许其他书有，因为有《Python 脑筋急转弯》和《Rust 脑筋急转弯》。但对于《Clojure 脑筋急转弯》，亚历克斯一直在 Clojure 的 Slack 里回答问题，大约十年了。所以总是出现相同的问题——而且因为这是一门经过深思熟虑设计的语言，同样没有破坏性变更，一切之所以这样运作都是有原因的——即使它可能
not feel right there's a reason so the the idea of the Brain Taser's book is to highlight those decisions that language isn't trying to trick you. So yeah, so that's the book. Are there any other? We can start to wind down because the listener can tell it's gotten a little bit quiet in the background. I'm not holding the mic. is this is jordan with the mic um uh next set of talks have have started and that means uh jose valim is talking so we're missing his live book talk but but it's okay we can wrap up here and say uh if folks and also i should say closure one of my i think top five programming languages my pl rank.com is written in ClosureScript.
感觉不对劲，但它是有原因的。“脑筋急转弯”这本书的想法就是突出那些决定，这门语言并不是在试图捉弄你。所以，是的，这就是那本书。还有其他的吗？我们可以开始收尾了，因为听众可以听出背景声音变安静了。我没拿话筒。这是拿着话筒的乔丹。下一组演讲已经开始了，这意味着何塞·瓦利姆正在演讲，所以我们错过了他的 Livebook 演讲，但没关系，我们可以在这里结束，并说——如果大家——而且我应该说，Clojure 是我的前五大编程语言之一。我的 pl rank.com 是用 ClojureScript 写的。
The thread first macro and thread last macro is just absolutely beautiful. One of the most elegant features. Rich Hickey, fantastic. We love it. Maybe we'll talk about Closure more when we do our relaunching of Lost in Lambdas. If people want to follow you, though, you're kind of active on Twitter. What's the best way for people to follow you? Just go subscribe to your pod, and it'll kick off at some
thread-first 宏和 thread-last 宏简直太美妙了。最优雅的功能之一。里奇·希基（Rich Hickey），太棒了。我们很喜欢它。也许在我们重新启动《迷失在 Lambda 中》时，我们会更多地讨论 Clojure。不过，如果人们想关注你，你在 Twitter 上还算活跃。大家关注你的最好方式是什么？只要去订阅你的播客，它就会在某个
point. How do people follow Jordan Miller? Yes, I have not deprecated my Twitter. I just don't get on it very often. So I'm laughing because I know we just had this conversation. I should do one of the hacky, one of the things. I should, LinkedIn? Oh, God. Hit me up on LinkedIn, I guess. No, I don't even know. I guess Twitter. Twitter is.
时候开始。人们怎么关注乔丹·米勒？是的，我没有弃用我的 Twitter。我只是不经常上去。所以我笑是因为我知道我们刚刚有过这段对话。我应该做一些老套的事情之一。我应该——LinkedIn？哦，天哪。去 LinkedIn 上找我吧，我想。不，我甚至不知道。我猜是 Twitter。Twitter 是。
People are going to hit you up on LinkedIn now. Oh, God. Yo, hit me up on eHarmony. No, no, don't. Do not do that. Just to be clear. And only hit me up on LinkedIn if you know me. Hmm.
人们现在要转去 LinkedIn 上找你了。哦，天哪。哟，在 eHarmony（婚恋网站）上联系我吧。不，不，别这样。千万别那样。澄清一下。只有在认识我的情况下才在 LinkedIn 上联系我。嗯。
I guess Twitter. Darn it. Okay. Twitter. Twitter it is. Thank you so much. Thank you. Go subscribe to Lost in Lambda's fantastic pod.
我猜还是 Twitter。该死。好吧。Twitter。那就 Twitter 吧。非常感谢。谢谢。去订阅《迷失在 Lambda 中》这个精彩的播客。
Thank you so much. All right. We are here at literally the conference just wrapped. Lambda Days 2023. And as promised, we managed to track them down right as the conference is ending. Simon Payton-Jones gave the opening keynote of Day 2 this morning with the CEO of Epic Games, Tim Sweeney. I guess first we'll ask, I mean, for folks that potentially don't know who you are, but we'll assume they do, maybe give a brief introduction and tell us what you thought of the conference, seeing as it just ended. So I'm Simon Peyton-Jones. I now work for Epic Games. I used to work for Microsoft Research. Really, I'm an academic computer scientist,
非常感谢。好的。我们现在所在的地方，会议刚刚结束。2023 年 Lambda Days。正如承诺的那样，我们在会议结束时设法找到了他们。西蒙·佩顿-琼斯（Simon Payton-Jones）今天上午与 Epic Games 的首席执行官蒂姆·斯威尼一起发表了第二天的主题演讲。我想首先我们要问的是，我的意思是，对于可能不知道你是谁的听众——不过我们假设他们知道——也许做一个简短的介绍，并告诉我们你对这次会议的看法，鉴于它刚刚结束。我是西蒙·佩顿-琼斯。我现在为 Epic Games 工作。我以前在微软研究院工作。实际上，我是一个学术计算机科学家，
but I'm fortunate enough to work for companies who, they need to do almost whatever I like. It's amazing. I really have a good job. Currently, I work on, I've spent my whole research career working on programming languages, functional programming languages in particular and at the moment this language Verse as well as continuing quite a lot of time spending on Haskell still I'm also quite involved in thinking about what young people should learn about computing
但我很幸运能为那些几乎允许我做任何我喜欢的事情的公司工作。这太棒了。我确实有一份好工作。目前，我从事——我整个研究生涯都在从事编程语言研究，特别是函数式编程语言。目前，我还在研究 Verse 这门语言，同时也花相当多的时间在 Haskell 上。我还深度参与了思考年轻人应该在学校教育中学习什么计算知识，
in their school education and working quite hard to reform what computing education looks like in the UK Yeah, I'll link, there's a couple podcasts I mean you've been on a bunch of podcasts, this won't be a full blown, you know, this will be just a short five minute or so interview. But I recall, I can't remember if it was the Haskell Exchange, but you've done a couple of podcasts where you focused purely on sort of like education reform in the UK. It's nice to see that happening in parts of the world, but hopefully, you know, other countries
并为改革英国的计算机教育面貌做出了很多努力。是的，我会链接——有一些播客，我的意思是上过很多播客，这不会是一个全面的，你知道的，这只会是一个五分钟左右的简短采访。但我记得——我不记得是不是 Haskell Exchange，但你做过几个完全专注于英国教育改革的播客。很高兴看到世界某些地方正在发生这种变化，但希望你知道，其他国家
and governments can take a cue from that because I think you would probably agree that's important. I think so. So I think the UK is, for the first time, shifted from thinking of computing as a kind of vocational skill you need to be able to use computers, to thinking of computing as a foundational piece of knowledge alongside natural science and mathematics, which all children should learn. Not primarily because they're going to get jobs in it, but primarily so that they can be equipped as citizens,
和政府能从中得到启发，因为我想你可能会同意这很重要。我也这么认为。所以我认为英国是第一次从将计算机视为一种使用计算机所需的职业技能的思维，转变为了将计算机视为一门基础知识——与自然科学和数学并列——所有儿童都应该学习的知识。这并不是主要因为他们会在其中找到工作，而是主要是为了让他们具备公民的素养。
to be sort of empowered citizens to know something about the technology they're using so they can make well-informed choices about it. It's a very big shift of perspective. I'll definitely find that podcast because I know you've talked at length about it and it is an interesting topic. Hopefully other countries will take a cue from the UK. We're two minutes into this let's um maybe give us a small because i think the keynotes actually i overheard uh the regular talks are going to take a few months to roll out but the keynotes i think they're going to try and get online within the
成为赋能的公民，了解他们正在使用的技术，从而能够做出明智的选择。这是一个非常大的视角转变。我一定会去听那个播客，因为我知道你详细谈过这个，这是一个很有趣的话题。希望其他国家能向英国看齐。我们已经录了两分钟了，让我们，嗯，也许简单介绍一下，因为我认为主题演讲其实——我无意中听到，常规演讲可能需要几个月时间才会推出，但主题演讲我想他们会尽量在
next couple of weeks um so give people a an overview of this very exciting i guess it wasn't announced at this conference it's been sort of out in the wild for at least a few months now. Tell people why they should be excited about Verse and the metaverse and what's happening at Epic Games in this area. So Verse is really the brainchild of Tim Sweeney, who is the founder and chief executive officer of Epic Games. He personally wrote the Unreal Engine, which is the game engine that is Epic's key piece of intellectual property and is used for all sorts of things, not just games, in virtual reality and architecture design and manufacturing design and is a sort of key building block of what we hope will become the metaverse. So, verse the programming language is also Tim's brainchild and he's been thinking about designing a new language for about 20 years.
接下来几周内上线，嗯，所以给听众概述一下这个非常令人兴奋的——我想这不是在这个会议上宣布的，它已经在野外（推出）至少几个月了。告诉大家为什么应该对 Verse、元宇宙以及 Epic Games 在这个领域正在做的事情感到兴奋。所以 Verse 实际上是蒂姆·斯weeney（Tim Sweeney）的脑力结晶，他是 Epic Games 的创始人兼首席执行官。他亲自编写了虚幻引擎（Unreal Engine），这是 Epic 的核心知识产权游戏引擎，被用于各种领域，不仅仅是游戏，还包括虚拟现实、建筑设计和制造设计，它是我们希望成为元宇宙的关键基石之一。所以，Verse 这个编程语言也是蒂姆的构想，他大约 20 年前就开始考虑设计一门新语言了。
My job, along with Leonard Augustin and several others, is to reverse engineer verse out of his head and make it apprehensible in form that engineers can build it and people can use it. So it's a functional logic programming language, which is a fairly, you know, functional logic programming is a niche within functional programming. So we aim to take that small niche of highly expressive programming language and kick it into the mainstream. That's quite an exciting thing to do. It's a very radical, you know, rethink of what programming should look like. It's not just another retread of Python by any means. Yeah, definitely. We'll link the keynote when it comes out. And I think actually there's already
我的工作，和伦纳德·奥古斯丁（Leonard Augustin）以及其他几个人一起，就是从他的脑海中逆向工程出 Verse，并将其具象化，以便工程师能够构建它，人们能够使用它。所以它是一门函数式逻辑编程语言，这相当于是，你知道的，函数式逻辑编程是函数式编程中的一个小众领域。因此，我们的目标是将这个极具表达力的编程语言的小众领域推向主流。这是一件非常令人兴奋的事情。这是对编程应该是什么样子的一个非常激进的、嗯，重新思考。它绝不仅仅是 Python 的又一次老调重弹。是的，绝对如此。当主题演讲发布时，我们会附上链接。而且我想实际上已经
a couple of videos on Verse that we can find on the Internet. It's open source, which is awesome that a company that's investing in the language like OutTheGecko is doing that. Is this something people can go and play with right now? Yes, there's a shipping version of Verse right at the moment. It's a kind of tiny fraction of the language that I showed today in the keynote that we showed today. But it's also bigger in other ways so the shipping language has is much more conventional in its in its framework and it has a fairly conventional type system but with subtyping and has classes and inheritance and that kind of stuff but the advantage is you can download and use it today to program the unreal engine in the fort environment. But the idea is that that language
有一些关于 Verse 的视频我们可以在互联网上找到。它是开源的，这太棒了，像 OutTheGecko 这样投资该语言的公司正在这样做。这是人们现在就可以去体验的东西吗？是的，目前有一个 Verse 的发布版本。它只是我今天在主题演讲中展示的语言的一小部分。但它在其他方面也更大，所以发布版本的语言在其框架中要传统得多，它有一个相当传统的类型系统，但带有子类型，有类和继承以及诸如此类的东西，但它的优点是你可以下载并在今天的堡垒（Fortnite）环境中使用它来为虚幻引擎编程。但我们的想法是，那门语言
will grow and become more capable and more like this Maxverse language, the one I described today. So this Shipverse will grow into Maxverse, if you like. Super exciting. Like I said, we'll link the keynote when it's out in the show notes. Any final thoughts? I mean, I guess I have to, while I have you here, I'm a huge, the listeners of the podcast know, I'm a huge Excel fan. At one point, I had three different versions of Excel. I still miss the color palette from Excel 2003. And you were instrumental in adding Lambda,
将会成长，变得更加强大，并且更像这个 Maxverse 语言，也就是我今天描述的那种。所以如果你愿意的话，这个发布版的 Verse 将会成长为 Maxverse。超级令人兴奋。就像我说的，当主题演讲发布时，我们会在节目简介中附上链接。有什么最后的想法吗？我的意思是，我想我不得不——趁你还在，我是个超级——播客的听众都知道，我是个超级 Excel 迷。有一段时间，我有三个不同版本的 Excel。我依然怀念 Excel 2003 的调色板。而你在加入 Lambda
one of probably the most exciting features that's been added to Excel in like the last two decades. Anything you want to share about the work that went into making that happen? Yeah, so it's, I think Lambda is the most exciting feature that's been in Excel for the last two or three decades. When I joined Microsoft in 1998, I thought, what is a functional programmer to do in a behemoth like Microsoft? So I thought, well, Microsoft already has the world's most widely used functional programming language. It's called Excel.
方面起到了关键作用，Lambda 可能是过去二十年里加入 Excel 的最令人兴奋的功能之一。有什么关于实现这一功能背后工作的分享吗？是的，所以，我认为 Lambda 是过去二三十年里 Excel 中最令人兴奋的功能。当我在 1998 年加入微软时，我想，一个函数式程序员在微软这样的庞然大物里能做什么？所以我想，好吧，微软已经有了世界上使用最广泛的函数式编程语言。它叫 Excel。
It's just that nobody thinks of it as a functional language. So if we did think of it in that way, look at it through that lens and made it a decent functional language, why? That would make functional programming the most widely used language in the world. there and give them room to grow and to become, well, they will nearly become functional programmers. That's quite exciting. So I think there's a lot of upward scope there. Now that the glass ceiling has been broken, I think we'll see a lot of further development. I think we've already got arrays as first class values, then we need arrays as values of cells, arrays nested within arrays. I've been advocating for this for a long time, but it does take a long time for a big mature product like Excel to absorb a radical idea like that. It took two decades of lobbying. In fact, there is a funny story associated with this, which is that I spent the first, I suppose the first six or so years I was working for Microsoft, I would go to Redmond every
只是没有人把它当作函数式语言来考虑。所以如果我们以这种方式思考它，通过那个镜头来看待它，并把它变成一门体面的函数式语言，为什么不呢？那将使函数式编程成为世界上使用最广泛的语言。放在那里并给它们成长的空间，最终，它们几乎会成为函数式程序员。这相当令人兴奋。所以我觉得那里的上升空间很大。既然玻璃天花板已经被打破，我想我们会看到很多进一步的发展。我想我们已经有了作为一等公民的值的数组，然后我们需要作为单元格值的数组，嵌套在数组中的数组。我为此倡导了很长时间，但对于 Excel 这样的大型成熟产品来说，要吸收这样一个激进的想法确实需要很长时间。这花了二十年的游说时间。事实上，这背后有一个有趣的故事，那就是我度过了最初的，我想是我在微软工作的头六年左右，每年都会去雷德蒙德
year and talk to the developers and they would say, yes, Simon, this is great. We're so going to do it. And then they'd phone me up later and say, oh, actually, we've got to put it, you know, we've got to put all our effort into moving from 32-bit to 64-bit machines. So we've cut it from this version. So then I got discouraged and I went away for about 10 years and did other things. And then I went back and do you know what had happened? Some of the people that I was talking to, the junior people that I was talking to, had become the bosses. So it was a very unusual tech transfer strategy. First of all, you make your converts.
一次，和开发人员交谈，他们会说，是的，西蒙，这太棒了。我们绝对要这么做。然后他们过会儿会打电话给我，说，哦，实际上，我们必须把——你知道的，我们必须把所有的精力都放在从 32 位迁移到 64 位机器上。所以我们从这个版本中砍掉了它。然后我灰心丧气了，离开了大约 10 年，去做别的事情。然后我回去，你知道发生了什么吗？我交谈过的一些人，我交谈过的那些初级人员，已经成了老板。所以这是一个非常不寻常的技术转让策略。首先，你培养你的皈依者。
Then you wait for them to be promoted. Then you come back and they say, oh, we should do this. And this time, because they were the bosses. If the senior people won't listen, talk to the junior folks and then just wait a decade until they're- Exactly. Just wait. That was the strategy as it turned out. I didn't plan it that way.
然后你等着他们升职。然后你回来，他们说，哦，我们应该这么做。而这一次，因为他们是老板。如果资深人士不听，就和年轻员工谈谈，然后等上十年，直到他们——没错。只是等待。事实证明，策略就是这样。我不是那样计划的。
And it worked. And we'll link, there's a talk I know you've given. I can't remember what conference where you sort of introduced the feature of Lambda and Excel. And I think also, was his name Jack Williams? Or was the individual that gave a talk here at Lambda Days, not just showing Lambda and Excel, but also like generative AI, LLM features being incorporated. It was all pretty, you were in that talk as well, right? No, actually, I was just arriving when he was finishing the talk. It was very sad.
而且它成功了。而且我们会附上链接，我知道你做过一次演讲。我不记得是哪个会议了，你在那里介绍了 Lambda 和 Excel 的功能。我想还有，那个人叫杰克·威廉姆斯（Jack Williams）吗？还是说，在 Lambda Days 上做演讲的那个人，不仅展示了 Lambda 在 Excel 中的应用，还展示了诸如生成式 AI、LLM 功能的整合。这一切都相当——你当时也参加了那个演讲，对吧？不，事实上，我到达时他刚好讲完。这太令人难过了。
But your listener should have a go at downloading Excel Labs, it's called, which is a kind of Microsoft-supported plugin for Excel that takes this Lambda idea a lot further. And it was written by Jack, written and implemented by Jack. And the idea is you can write a spreadsheet which has a lot of cells interconnected, and then you can press a button, and it'll take the contents of that spreadsheet and turn it into a single Lambda.
但你的听众应该去尝试下载一个叫做 Excel Labs 的东西，这是一个微软支持的 Excel 插件，它将 Lambda 的这个想法推得更远。它是杰克编写的，由杰克编写和实现的。这个想法是你可以编写一个包含许多相互连接的单元格的电子表格，然后你可以按下一个按钮，它就会获取该电子表格的内容并将其转换为单个 Lambda。
That's pretty amazing, because now it takes the form of textual source code that you can edit and keep in GitHub and reuse more critically, reuse. So you can take that spreadsheet and effectively call it hundreds of times on different data. So that was the original vision of functions in Excel was worksheets as functions, right? You nominate the input cells, you nominate the output cell, that's your function definition. Jack's implemented that finally. Excel Labs, give it a try.
这真是太惊人了，因为现在它采用了文本源代码的形式，你可以对其进行编辑，将其保存在 GitHub 中，并且更关键的是，可以重复使用。所以你可以拿那个电子表格，在不同的数据上有效地调用它数百次。所以这最初就是 Excel 中函数的愿景，即作为函数的的工作表，对吧？你指定输入单元格，你指定输出单元格，这就是你的函数定义。杰克终于实现了这一点。Excel Labs，去试试吧。
Excel Labs, link in the show notes. I think also they mentioned, was it AFE Advanced Function Editor or something that they're working on? That's part of the same thing, I think. This whole plug-in gives you a function editor in which you can write both textually and I think in the Excel formula language. In a little palette on the side, you can write lambdas with lets and layout and comments and so forth, I think. It's pretty wild. The next editor after VS Code that Microsoft is going to release is going to be inside Excel, potentially. No, but it is VS Code, I think.
Excel Labs，链接在节目简介中。我想他们还提到了，是不是 AFE 高级函数编辑器（Advanced Function Editor）或者他们正在开发的类似东西？我认为这是同一件事的一部分。整个插件为你提供了一个函数编辑器，你既可以用文本方式编写，也可以在 Excel 公式语言中编写。在侧边的一个小调色板中，你可以用 let、布局和注释等编写 lambda，我想。这太疯狂了。微软要发布的继 VS Code 之后的下一个编辑器，可能将会在 Excel 内部。不，但它就是 VS Code，我想。
Oh, it is VS Code. Because you don't want to re-implement all of that stuff. So I think Jack just hash-included VS Code there. But you're not just typing into an enormously long formula in that little formula bar. You're having a proper VS Code editor. Yeah, that's amazing. Now substantial lambdas. Do well anything, because now Excel has just become too incomplete. You can do anything because you have lambda. Are you sure you still don't work for Microsoft,
哦，它就是 VS Code。因为你不想重新实现所有这些东西。所以我想杰克只是在那里哈希引入（hash-included）了 VS Code。但你不仅仅是在那个小公式栏里输入一个极其漫长的公式。你拥有一个真正的 VS Code 编辑器。是的，这太惊人了。现在有实质性的 Lambda 了。做什么都可以，因为现在 Excel 变得太无所不能了。你可以做任何事，因为你有 lambda。你确定你依然不在微软工作吗？
I guess, that many years you're promoting the products? I'm deeply enthusiastic. I mean, Excel just has that market. And I think the fact that it now, I think the Excel team now have absorbed into their DNA the idea of Excel as a programming language that they want to grow and develop. They could do, call Python from Excel as well. I just think that it could open the door to end users becoming programmers. And that has nothing to do with a single company, but it's quite a seismic thing to do that can, you know, can it can multiply the audience of
我想，这么多年你一直在推广这些产品？我满怀热情。我的意思是，Excel 确实拥有那个市场。而且我认为，事实是现在，我认为 Excel 团队现在已经将 Excel 作为一种他们想要发展和拓展的编程语言的理念融入到了他们的 DNA 中。他们也可以从 Excel 调用 Python。我只是认为这可以为最终用户成为程序员打开大门。这与单一公司无关，但这是一件相当震撼的事情，它可以，你知道的，它可以成倍增加受众群体
people who would never think of themselves as programmers, but are now writing significant pieces of code, it could, you know, there are 10 or 100 times as many of them as there are of us. And so we should respect them and love them. And I'm really pleased that Microsoft is sort of moving Excel in this direction. I hope they continue to do so. I'll try and find the number, but I think I saw some graph where it was an estimated number
那些从不认为自己是程序员的人，现在却在编写重要的代码，这可能会，你知道的，他们的数量是我们的 10 到 100 倍。所以我们应该尊重他们、爱他们。我真的很高兴微软正以这种方式推动 Excel 发展。我希望他们继续这样做。我会试着找那个数字，但我记得我看到过某个图表，里面是估计的
of programmers per language. And they went from number five or number 10 up to number one. And then they covered most of the top ones, Python, Java, C++. And I was like, what is number one? And then number one, it was like, I think a quarter billion or something users of Excel. And that was the number
每种语言的程序员数量。他们从第五或第十名上升到第一名。然后他们涵盖了大多数顶尖的语言，Python、Java、C++。当时我在想，第一名是什么？然后第一名，大概是两亿五千万左右的 Excel 用户。这就是
one language. And I was like, oh yeah, I didn't think of that. Anyway, so thank you so much for taking the time. If people want to keep up to date with the latest Inverse or the latest things that you're working at, where should people go? Twitter? Do you have a blog? No. So I have a homepage, which I, you know, so mainly I keep up to date my publications, right? Because I mainly crank things out by trying to write papers. I've been a bit slow recently, but there's a paper about Verse there. There is, I mean, the Epic itself has a whole site for the shipping Verse product, and that has a community attached to it.
第一名语言。然后我想，哦，是的，我没想到这一点。无论如何，非常感谢你抽出时间。如果人们想了解 Verse 的最新动态或者你正在从事的最新工作，人们应该去哪里？Twitter？你有博客吗？没有。所以我有个人主页，我，你知道的，所以主要是我会更新我的出版物，对吧？因为我主要是通过试着写论文来产出东西的。我最近进度有点慢，但那里有一篇关于 Verse 的论文。我的意思是，Epic 本身有一个专门针对发布版 Verse 产品的整个网站，并且附带了一个社区。
And I hope that we may eventually develop a community around the Maxverse stuff, but because it's a very small team at the moment, we haven't yet got a sort of open discussion going. Awesome. Thank you so much for taking the time and hopefully we'll run into each other at a few. I mean, you're going to be at ZuriHack. Yeah, I'm going straight
我希望我们最终能够围绕 Maxverse 的东西建立一个社区，但因为目前团队非常小，我们还没有开始进行某种公开讨论。太棒了。非常感谢你抽出时间，希望我们能在某个活动上偶遇。我的意思是，你会去 ZuriHack 吗？对，我直接从
from here to ZuriHack to a three-day tutorial about the insides of GHC, you know, the bowels of GHC and its type checker. It's going to be a lot of fun. But I enjoyed your talk about combinators as well. Yeah. That was a lot of fun. And array languages.
这里去 ZuriHack，参加一个关于 GHC 内部机制的为期三天的教程，你知道的，GHC 的内部及其类型检查器。那将会非常有趣。不过我也很喜欢你关于组合子的演讲。是的。那非常有趣。还有数组语言。
I'd love to make... I was wanting to ask you about what you think about Remora, my friend Erlin Shivers, and also how to turn... You know, what would it take? I sort of feel as if it ought to be possible to build a library in Haskell and then put some work into implementation that would make Haskell a sort of, like a host language for a really good array language, if you like.
我很想做……我一直想问你对 Remora 的看法，我的朋友艾尔林·希弗斯（Erlin Shivers），以及如何转变……你知道的，需要什么？我有点觉得，在 Haskell 中构建一个库，然后投入一些工作进行实现，使 Haskell 成为一个真正优秀的数组语言的宿主语言，如果你愿意的话，这应该是可能的。
Because building whole new languages, however good they are, it's a big engineering exercise, right? So if you can sort of kind of submarine something into a language that already exists and already is widely deployed that can be another way so i wanted to talk to you about that yeah so i've i discovered at this conference uh someone pointed to me towards uh leonard's library ortho taupe i believe is yeah and uh i had no idea that he had given a talk on it last year and so i got i managed to talk to him a bit about it.
因为构建全新的语言，无论它们多么优秀，都是一项巨大的工程练习，对吧？所以如果你能把某种东西潜入一个已经存在且已被广泛部署的语言中，那可能是另一种方式，所以我很想跟你聊聊这个。是的，所以我在这次会议上发现——有人向我指出了伦纳德的库 ortho taupe，我记得是这样的——是的，我不知道他去年做过关于它的演讲，所以我设法和他聊了一会儿。
And he said it's a little bit unwieldy and that there's three different types for however much static typing you need for your arbitrarily ranked arrays. But it did sound like he had done a little bit of work in that space. And it is, I mean, this is going to turn into a whole hour conversation. So we should end it. But, yeah, maybe at a future date and time, we'll bring you on to the podcast and we can do a whole history of Simon, Peyton, Jones and your thoughts on sort of the array language world and the ideas there. I would like Haskell to be the world's best array language too.
他说这有点笨拙，对于你为任意秩的数组所需的静态类型量，有三种不同的类型。但听起来他确实在该领域做了一些工作。而且，我的意思是，这将会变成一个长达一小时的对话。所以我们应该结束它。但是，是的，也许在未来的某个日期和时间，我们会邀请你上播客，我们可以做一期关于西蒙·佩顿·琼斯（Simon Peyton Jones）的完整历史，以及你对数组语言世界的看法和那里的想法。我也希望 Haskell 成为世界上最好的数组语言。
Because arrays, it's fundamentally functional programming, isn't it? Yes. So, you know, let's just make it good. Make it good. And we have the advantages. We have our fingers on the implementation. We want something from the type checker. We can make it do that. That is true. It's not.
因为数组，从根本上说就是函数式编程，不是吗？是的。所以，你知道的，让我们把它做好。把它做好。而且我们有优势。我们的手指搭在实现上。我们想要类型检查器的某种功能。我们可以让它做到这一点。确实如此。不是的。
Haskell is, by design, a laboratory in which we explore and push the bleeding edge of what static typing means and maybe what performance means and what arrays mean, I think. So, I don't want Haskell to be a static thing. We're tussling with the tension between making it a stable base that companies can build on and rely on so that then, you know, they're not at a whim.
Haskell 在设计上是一个实验室，我们在其中探索并突破静态类型意味着什么、也许性能意味着什么以及数组意味着什么的尖端领域，我想。所以，我不希望 Haskell 是一个一成不变的东西。我们正在努力平衡这样一种张力：既要使其成为企业可以构建和依赖的稳定基础，这样他们就不会一时兴起
We change something that then gives them three weeks of fixing because their things fall down. So we have to look after them. But also, we still want it to be a laboratory for innovation. I think so far we're walking that line with care and some pain but quite successfully i think this is uh this just made me think that there is technically a few different implementations quote unquote just you know varying different extents in different languages so there's a library slash language called april that's a april apl implementation and common list i think there's another one called may which is uh an apl implementation enclosure then there's one in juliaist. I think there's another one called May, which is an APL
我们改变了某些东西，然后给他们带来三周的修复时间，因为他们的东西崩溃了。所以我们必须照顾好他们。但同时，我们仍然希望它成为一个创新的实验室。我认为到目前为止，我们正在小心翼翼且带有一点痛苦但相当成功地走这条线。这让我想起，技术上确实有几种不同的实现，引用和未引用——你知道的，在不同的语言中程度不同——所以有一个叫做 april 的库/语言，它是一个 APL 实现，在 Common Lisp 中，我想还有一个叫做 may 的，它是一个 APL
implementation in Clojure. Then there's one in Julia. I don't think that one's called June, but it sounds like, you know, you're hearing it here first from Simon that there should be an APL in Haskell. It should, yeah. I think they should. Yeah, maybe we should. And it takes some work, right? It takes cycles to make things good. And that means it takes some committed
在 Clojure 中的实现。然后还有一个在 Julia 中的。我不认为那个叫 June，但听起来，你知道的，你是从西蒙这里第一次听到，Haskell 中应该有一个 APL。它应该，是的。我想它们应该。是的，也许我们应该。这需要一些工作，对吧。使事情变好需要周期。这意味着需要一些坚定的
people to put the work in. But it could be fun. We'll end it there. Thank you so much, Simon, for taking the time. And we hope to run into you at a future conference. We will. Yeah, good. Thanks a lot.
人来投入工作。但这可能会很有趣。我们就聊到这里吧。非常感谢西蒙抽空参与。我们希望在未来的会议上与你偶遇。会的。好的，非常感谢。
Awesome. Thank you. Once again, thank you to all of the speakers, organizers, and attendees that agreed to be interviewed over the last two episodes. Be sure to check your show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for any of the talks or things that we mentioned in either of these two episodes, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave comments, questions or thoughts on either of the episodes. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了。谢谢。再次感谢在过去两期节目中同意接受采访的所有演讲者、组织者和与会者。请务必查看你的播客应用中的节目简介，或者访问 ADSP the podcast dot com，了解我们在这两期节目中提到的任何演讲或事情，以及一个 GitHub 讨论链接，你可以在其中留下对这两期节目的评论、问题或想法。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。这期节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。